as-tu une apprécié que le gouvernement
faisait tout pour limiter l'augmentation
des prix tout en rappelant que la
situation de la France était mieux
qu'ailleurs regardez inverse aujourd'hui
une inflation qui est la conséquence de
nos dépendances nous l'avons mieux
maîtrisé que nombre de nos voisins mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe au fond si je
devais donner un chiffre sur l'année
2022 et bien pour les ménages d'abord
donc compatriotes qui nous écoutent on
va continuer d'aider mais en adaptant
les choses sur l'électricité le gaz il y
aura une hausse de 15% dans les premiers
mois c'est beaucoup mais quand je
regarde ce que ça devrait être c'est
beaucoup moins c'est à dire que ça
devrait être des hausse de plus de 100%
mais elles ne sont pas liées au
gouvernement tout ça c'est ce qu'on
subit de l'extérieur c'est un impôt de
l'extérieur cette inflation mais donc
l'État va prendre sa part et continuera
à le faire il va continuer en 2023 en
passant cette hausse de 15% mais pas
plus
alors
ça déjà c'est le premier truc c'est le
premier truc et puis après effectivement
il va s'adresser aux petites entreprises
il était très attendue là dessus
alors l'aide aux petites entreprises
notamment les boulangers regardez ce
qu'il a dit le président
les très petites entreprises comme les
petites collectivités locales elles vont
avoir la même aide que les ménages c'est
à dire elles n'auront une hausse de leur
électricité de l'orgasme que de 15%
. ça c'est très important parce que
parfois c'était x 3 x 4 ensuite sur nos
petites et moyennes entreprises et les
petites entre les très petites qui sont
très consommatrices d'électricité haut
de gaz je pense à nos boulangers parce
que nos boulangers ils sont pas dans le
mécanisme à 15% par exemple on va leur
mettre en place un système qui va
amortir le choc des prix d'électricité
et faire que si ça s'envole et ben en
quelque sorte on va vous garantir un
prix raisonnable
alors ça ce que ça vous va monsieur
Bonger fait
très bien voilà donc les boulangers sont
contents et un boulanger dans le public
il est content donc je suis content mais
c'est important mais c'est vrai bah
voilà l'insécurité c'est également
exprimé au sujet de l'insécurité qui est
plus que jamais d'actualité et la tenue
à préciser qu'il ne souhaitait pas faire
de lien entre immigration et insécurité
regarde je ne ferai jamais un lien
existentiel entre l'immigration et
l'insécurité nous sommes un pays qui a
toujours eu des immigrés qui a toujours
accueilli et intégré ce que je veux
qu'on puisse faire c'est accueillir
celles et ceux qu'on veut protéger qui
fuit des combats ou qui sont des
combattants de la liberté l'asile et
intégrer celles et ceux qui viennent
étudier ou qui viennent nous aider à
réussir et à bâtir le pays l'immigration
économique et je veux lutter contre
l'immigration illégale et donc oui quand
on regarde aujourd'hui la délinquance à
Paris on ne peut pas ne pas voir que
la moitié au moins des délinquants des
fêtes délinquance qu'on observe viennent
de personnes qui sont des étrangers soit
en situation irrégulière soit en attente
deux titres
voilà oui il veut pas faire de lien
entre les étrangers et la moitié des
délices et les étrangers
quand même alors mine de rien parce que
si la moitié des délices et des
étrangers tu fais quand même aller entre
les étrangers vous avez pas compris ce
qu'il vient de dire là alors j'étais sur
mon rendez-vous avec Béatrice
avant de avant de français vous imaginez
voter caca mou donc c'est moi
il s'en sort en disant si je puis dire
lien existentiel il y a pas de lien
existentiel et c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment un mot ambigu parce que après
en donnant effectivement le chiffre de
la délinquance à Paris 50% d’étranger là
clairement il met le cap à droite mais
il est obligé en ce moment d'avoir des
mots de sécurité de ce qui se passe mais
il est très ambigu sur le sujet
pendant la campagne il aurait jamais
sorti ça
émission il me dérange en fait ça
ressemble plutôt à court théorique à une
interview il a aucune contradiction
faite de lui Caroline aurait le
contredit pas du tout elle est super non
mais il a pas de traditions
à mon avis c'est c'est vu comme ça c'est
sûr mais c'est le format de l'émission
il a pas de cette forme non plus en
plateau quand on sait qu'il avait refusé
de 2022 là il a 1h pour s'exprimer tout
seul c'est un cours théorique et
franchement ça me gêne qui parle comme
ça tout seul pendant 1h
il y a pas de contradiction c'est
dérangeant pour nous expliquer qu'il va
nous faire des cadeaux avec nos impôts
pour nous expliquer tout ça en fait il a
il nous a expliqué juste comme un père
Noël qu'il allait nous faire des cadeaux
et regarder les autres pays et moi j'en
ai marre qu'à chaque fois qu'ils
prennent la parole c'est mon Président
je le respecte mais à chaque fois c'est
pour me parler de ce qui se passe dans
les autres pays j'en ai strictement rien
à [ __ ] de ce qui se passe je m'en fous
de ce qui se passe dans les autres pays
regarde ce qui se passe ici aujourd'hui
on a du beurre qui a 2,50 €. on a on a
un des steaks cachés 10 steaks cachés
c'est 10 € au mecs réveille-toi dis
steaks haché 10 € tout augmenté tout est
en train de partir en sucette on
m'explique tous les jours que c'est pas
l'Ukraine alors on m'explique que c'est
l'électricité va dire au boulanger qui
doit payer l'électricité 4 fois plus
cher c'est pas lui c'était qui alors les
boulangeries ah bah très bien il faut
que ça évite en tout cas faut que ça
évite mais pourquoi ça va vite parce
qu'on en parle hier parce que ça ça
il était président bah c'est parfait
alors sur les boulangers
moi je m'en fous j'ai encore mis un
plein tout à l'heure à 135 € j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] parce que grâce à toi je
peux le faire mais je me redis que 6
mois j'étais encore chauffeur livreur et
uniquement que je dois faire livreur
avec mes 1980 balles déjà j'aurais été
en galère avec des courses à 200 €, il y
a rien dans ton caddy tu as 3 sacs quand
tu sors du supermarché des plans
d'essence à 2 €, on est content quand on
met les j'ai mis de l'essence j'étais
content je sais bien il y a de l'essence
130 euros je vois des gens des vampires
à les mettre de l'essence à minuit on
est en France il y a des vampires qui
m'a donné ah oui les mecs qui vont tous
à minuit pour mettre de l'essence et où
tu vas là et puis après le film je vais
aller mettre de l'essence il y a pas la
queue arrête arrête arrête de déconner
avec ça ça vous déconne avec ça mais
faut pas déconner avec ça alors ces
événements là le monde de la crise là
arrêtez ils sont chez eux ils ont ils
ont pas de monde de crise ils ont de
l'essence ils ont tout ce qu'il faut ils
ont rien ils viennent nous nous saouler
avec leur franchement ça m'a saoulé j'ai
fait les courses et je vais donner
encore
une dernière question
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en train de se faire carotte partout
dans les magasins il y a le scan on peut
faire les courses avec le scan je
m'amuse en ce moment à faire les courses
avec le scan et je m'amuse à regarder
les prix affichés dans le supermarché
c'est pour ça que supermarché à chaque
fois que je t'appelle le petit le petit
Pedro est attendu en caisse numéro aux
gens qu'on parle un gros budget si vous
pouvez faire les courses avec le scan
c'est le prix que vous allez scanner
c'est le prix que vous allez retrouver à
la caisse et vous faites faites
attention ce qui a marqué dans les
rayons c'est pas les vrais prix même la
grande distribution il se foutent de
notre temps j'ai pas compris est-ce que
tu peux nous répéter ça parce que j'ai
l'impression
il y a des magasins
en course faut pas faire des trucs à
chat rapide quand tu vas faire tes
courses dans les grandes surfaces hein
tu peux prendre scanner tes articles au
code barre sur le moment même et le
score bar qui va se scanner c'est ce que
tu vas retrouver en caisse ce sera le
même montant et ça va te faire un cumul
de tes achats là par exemple tu as 100
€, tu t'en rends en instantané j'ai vu
des pâtes moi afficher 30 sur mon scan
sur mon scan elle passe à 1 € 53 si tu
te fais baiser de 20 centimes à chaque
fois bah la caisse il te manque 20
balles et ça la grande surface ils le
font quasiment tous j'ai essayé parce
que je suis psychopathe et Gérande à
[ __ ] de mes journées j'ai essayé
plusieurs magasins et je dis aux gens
qu'on parle gros ça veut dire que tu as
fait ça que sur les pâtes
les gens savent pas parce que tu as des
gens qui ont pas d'oseille qui font
confiance le prix il est là le magasin
les mecs on va s'arranger avec un kilo
de rien je vais manger des pâtes
[Applaudissements]
psychopathe aubergine 3,80 les
aubergines quoi
[Applaudissements]
apparemment il peut faire une mousse à
caca
je veux bien qu'il me parle des autres
pays je veux bien qu'on soutien de la
guerre en Ukraine je suis pas de
problème mais faut avoir les moyens de
soutenir la gare en crème je vous le dis
il faut avoir les moyens moi je m'en
fous je suis grâce à poche je suis bien
je m'en fous on est tous bien au bac tu
seras tout seul
regarde regarde le beurre 25% non mais
sérieux regardez alors regardez le
poulet
cachés 11 euros quoi mec dis steaks
cachés à Lidl 10 steaks hachés 11 euros
dans les magasins les moins chers 1 € le
steak hachée moi mais tu devais déjà
mangé des pâtes je voulais manger des
steaks et des pâtes
j'achète que chez cuisine mais et donc
tu as pris un kilo de gruyère
d'abord
Netflix ah l'air
au fromage
mais franchement c'est incroyable
non mais Raymond on rigole mais il a
raison
j'ai acheté des chocolatines
[Rires]
bien sûr que j'ai toutes les cartes
Monoprix
là j'étais dégoûté
vous allez faire vos courses Daniel
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec mon
homme on s'en fout de la petite famille
non mais c'est vrai que c'est hyper dur
quoi c'est vrai que nous on est
privilégié donc c'est en parler
c'est hyper intéressant ce que tu as dit
sur le scan les prix et les gens sont
vraiment galère de thunes faites avec le
Skam tu as raison faites pas ce qu'il y
a écrit à la fin le mec je l'ai
interpellé moi parce que moi tu sais
comment je suis interpellé le mec du
rayon je dis explique-moi pourquoi
regarde quand je le passe au scan
regarde ce que ça mais pourquoi c'est là
c'est ce qui m'a sorti mais ça ça se
trouve on a oublié de changer les trucs
on n'a pas changé depuis deux trois
jours on fait quoi si tu nous mets 20
balles à chaque fois juste parce que
vous avez pas changé les trucs les mecs
voilà c'est c'est un coup de gueule
parce que nous on est confortable on met
sans regarder les prix bien sûr
c'est à la fin sur son article 20
centimes
après 60 balles et tu fais c'est énorme
et oui on rigole pas jamais rigoler
c'est bon on rigole pas j'ai le droit de
te voilà te Titi un peu quoi non mais
c'est vrai voilà bon je suis une petite
astuces pour les gens qui ne savent pas
bon je pense que tout le monde le sait
mais c'est important de regarder le prix
au kilo faut pas comparer les articles
non parce qu'il y a des gens qui compare
deux articles il faut toujours regarder
le prix au kilo et c'est comme ça qu'on
fait des économies
et à côté vous avez les yaourts 24
yaourts en promo et des fois les 6
yaourts sont moins chers en prenant au
cas par cas que de prendre les 24 les 24
sont plus chers
la promo est beaucoup plus cher
trois paquets de 6 ça vous fait 18
yaourts que prendre les 24 de large mais
oui les mecs attendez ah les fils de
like donc le prix au kilo il est indiqué
sur l'étiquette juste en dessous du prix
en tout petit lot de yaourt
regardez le prix au kilo toujours et
donc ça c'est pas le premier prix c'est
le prix qui est marqué en tout petit en
dessous le prix au kilo et c'est comme
ça qu'on compare deux articles d'un même
rayon quoi voilà
ils ont changé le packaging ils mettent
moins de gâteaux par paquet pour le même
prix donc en fait regardez la Clio
donc les gens ont l'impression d'acheter
la même chose au même prix et en fait il
y en a moins donc voilà c'est comme dans
le style de Castaldi
il y en a moins dans le paquet
[Rires]
moi j'ai appris des trucs et c'est rare
dans cette émission avec vous